CHRIS: IT IS GOOD TO BE BACK.
LOOK AT THAT SET OF BIGS.
WE HAVE A.D., DWIGHT, DEANDRE
JORDAN.
THAT IS LOOKING NICE.
THERE IS DWIGHT YELLING.
A.D. IS LAUGHING AND DEANDRE IS
PRETENDING TO YELL.
I'VE GOT GOOD NEWS FOR
EVERYBODY.
A.D. IS HERE.
HE'S GOT THE HEADSET ON.
NEWLYWED.
PACKERS ARE PLAYING SOME
FOOTBALL ALL OF A SUDDEN.
A.D., GOOD TO BE YOU RIGHT NOW,
ISN'T IT?
ANTHONY: LAKERS SEASON IS BACK.
IT HAS BEEN A GREAT WEEK.
ALLIE: THERE IS THAT, TOO,
LAKERS.
CHRIS: THE LAKERS ARE STARTING
TOO.
ALLIE: CAN I START THIS OFFERS
FOR GET INTO BASKETBALL.
AGAIN, CONGRATULATIONS TO YOU ON
GETTING MARRIED.
WHAT IS MORE ACCOMPLISHING FOR
YOU, HITTING THE GAME-WINNER
VERSUS DENVER IN THE WESTERN
CONFERENCE FINALS OR MAILING
YOUR PERFORMANCE TO YOUR NOW
WIFE?
ANTHONY: THERE'S ONLY ONE ANSWER
.
I CAN'T GET IN TROUBLE THIS
EARLY.
COME ON.
[LAUGHTER]
I HAD A GREAT TIME.
IT WAS FUN.
I THINK THE PERFORMANCE TO MY
WIFE WAS DEFINITELY THE BETTER
PERFORMANCE.
WE HAD A BLAST.
WE HAD A GREAT TIME.
CHRIS: BIG GAME COULD SING AS
WELL.
YOU READ HIM PRETTY HIGH.
IT TAKES GUTS.
JAMES: YOU GOT THE PIPES.
NICE LITTLE BARITONE, DIFFERENT
OCTAVES.
COOL UNDER PRESSURE.
ANTHONY: WE COULD GO ON TOUR.
JAMES: WE COULD DO A LITTLE DUO
AT SOME POINT.
I KNOW YOU HAVE OTHER THINGS TO
FOCUS ON.
COOL, PASSION.
CHRIS: I LOVE THAT WE ARE THREE
MINUTES IN AND WE HAVEN'T
THOUGHT ABOUT IT BASKETBALL
QUESTION.
ALLIE: HAPPY WIFE, HAPPY LIFE.
CHRIS: NOW WE COULD GET TO THE
LAKERS.
ALLIE: WHEN YOU FINISH THE
SEASON AFTER THAT FIRST-ROUND
EXIT, I HAVE BEEN VERY EXCITED
TO TALK TO YOU BECAUSE YOU ARE
EXCITED ABOUT GETTING BACK TO
YOUR OFF-SEASON ROUTINE.
WHAT DID THAT LOOK LIKE?
WHAT WAS THE DAY AND THE LIFE
THIS SUMMER IN TERMS OF HOOPS
FOR ANTHONY DAVIS?
ANTHONY: JUST GETTING MY BODY
RIGHT.
I WAS VERY DISAPPOINTED IN
MYSELF BECAUSE OF THE INNER --
INJURIES.
WE COULD SAY SHORT OFF-SEASON.
IT KIND OF DID HAVE AN EFFECT ON
A LOT OF GUYS BODIES AND HOURLY.
FOR ME, I WANTED TO GET BACK TO
MY 12, 14, 16 WEEK OFF-SEASON
TRAINING THAT I AM ACCUSTOMED
TO, TO GET MY BODY REPAIRED FOR
THE SEASON.
I WAS ABLE TO DO THAT THIS
SUMMER.
I FEEL GREAT, BODY IS HEALTHY.
I'M EXCITED TO GO BACK OUT HERE
AND SHOW THE WORLD WHAT I HAVE
BEEN DOING.
I HAVE BEEN KEEPING IT UNDER
WRAPS.
I DON'T DO THE CAMERAS AND STUFF
ANYWAY.
CHRIS: ONLY A -- IF YOU ARE
SINGING.
ANTHONY: I TRY TO KEEP IT UNDER
WRAPS AND KEEP MY HEAD DOWN AND
JUST WORK THIS SUMMER.
CHRIS: I LOVE THAT ABOUT YOU.
WHETHER IT IS REPORTS, OR TALK
AROUND THE NBA.
IT IS ALWAYS A TOPIC OF OF
PLAYING MORE CENTER.
IS THERE A DIFFERENT MINDSET OR
DID IT CHANGE THE WAY YOU
PREPARE FOR THIS OFF-SEASON?
ANTHONY: NO, TO BE HONEST IT WAS
KIND OF THE SAME WAY.
AS FAR AS THE CENTER THING, I
HAVE NO PROBLEM WITH IT.
ME AND FRANK HAD CONVERSATIONS
ABOUT IT.
ME, LEBRON, AND RUSS HAD
CONVERSATIONS.
I'M COOL WITH IT, I THINK IT
HELPS OUR TEAM.
THERE WILL BE GAMES WHERE D.J.
AND DWIGHT START AT CENTER.
THE PLAN NOW IS TO START ME AT
CENTER OR MAYBE START THEM, I'M
NOT SURE HOW FRANK HAS IT SET.
I KNOW I WILL BE PLAYING CENTER
A LOT MORE.
JAMES: WHEREVER YOU PLAY WILL BE
BENEFICIAL FOR THE TEAM.
I AM OLD SCHOOL.
I LIKE INSIDE OUT FIRST.
I WANTED TO TALK TO A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT YOUR OFF-SEASON WORKOUT.
I KNOW IN MY CAREER IT TOOK ME
TWO OR THREE YEARS TO REALIZE
THE STRONGER MY BODY IS, THE
MORE I COULD WITHSTAND.
THE MORE I COULD TAKE ON
INJURIES AND THINGS OF THAT
NATURE.
HOW HAVE YOU FELT ABOUT THAT AT
THIS POINT IN YOUR CAREER GIVEN
THE FACT THAT YOU DO TAKE A LOT
OF PUNISHMENT NIGHT IN AND NIGHT
OUT THE WAY TEAMS LET YOU
PHYSICALLY AND HOW THAT HAS
WORKED OUT FOR YOU?
ANTHONY: MY FIRST YEAR HERE I
HAD A GREAT OFF-SEASON.
I PLAYED 72 GAMES OR SOMETHING
LIKE THAT.
A COUPLE OF THEM WERE JUST
BECAUSE OF REST.
THE PLAYOFFS I DID NOT MISS A
GAME.
LAST YEAR WAS KIND OF A SEASON
THAT I WANT TO PUT BEHIND ME
BECAUSE OF ALL THE INJURIES IN
THE AMOUNT OF TIME I MISSED.
NOT BEING ABLE TO HELP MY SEEM
ON THE FLOOR -- TEAM ON THE
FLOOR.
IT IS A HUGE PART OF WHAT US
ATHLETES GO THROUGH.
I REALIZED THE SAME THING YOU
REALIZED.
THE STRONGER YOUR BODY IS, THE
MORE YOU TRAIN YOUR BODY IN THE
OFF-SEASON AND ALSO MAINTAINING
DURING THE SEASON, YOU COULD
WITHSTAND THOSE INJURIES.
YOU NEVER KNOW HOW YOU COULD
FALL OR THE POSITION YOU HAVE TO
MOVE IN.
ABLE TO LIFT A LOT OF WEIGHTS
AND STRENGTHEN THE MUSCLES AND
LIGAMENTS IN YOUR BODY, YOU HAVE
A HIGHER PERCENTAGE CHANCE OF
WITHSTANDING THOSE INJURIES.
OR THE BIGGER INJURIES THAT SOME
PEOPLE HAVE GOTTEN IN THE PAST
SEASON.
I'VE BEEN TRAINING MY BUTT OFF.
[LAUGHTER]
I WANT TO MAKE SURE I'M
AVAILABLE TO MY TEAM WHENEVER
THEY NEED ME.
ALLIE: WE KNOW THE END GOAL FOR
ALL OF YOU IS BRINGING NUMBER 18
TO THE FRANCHISE.
WE KNOW IT ALSO STARTS WITH THE
THREE OF YOU.
YOU, LEBRON, RUSS IT IS ONE
THING TO TALK ABOUT IT.
IT IS ANOTHER THING TO BE ABOUT
IT.
BASED ON THE CONVERSATIONS YOU
GUYS HAVE HAD, WHAT GIVES YOU
THE CONFIDENCE THAT THE THREE OF
YOU COULD LEAD THIS TEAM TO
WHERE IT ULTIMATELY WANTS TO BE?
ANTHONY: ONE WORD, SACRIFICE.
WE ALL SACRIFICE FOR THE
BETTERMENT OF THE TEAM.
BEFORE RUSS GOT HERE AND RIGHT
AFTER RUSS GOT TRADED HERE, WE
TALKED ABOUT THAT.
THE ONLY WAY THIS WILL WORK IS
IF WE ALL SACRIFICE.
ME AND LEBRON HAVE DONE IT.
NOW BRINGING RUSS IN, WHO WANTS
TO WIN.
HE IS VERY UNSELFISH.
WE ALL WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT --
WE WANT THE BEST FOR EACH OTHER
AND FOR OUR TEAM.
IT STARTS WITH US THREE.
WE WILL BE ABLE TO MAKE THIS
WORK.
WE WILL MAKE EVERYONE BETTER,
HOPEFULLY MAKE EACH OTHER
BETTER.
AS LONG AS WE HAVE ONE COMMON
GOAL IN MIND, IT IS ALL ABOUT
BANNER NUMBER 18.
I THINK WE SHOULD BE IN A GOOD
POSITION TO REACH THAT GOAL.
CHRIS: WE APPRECIATE YOUR TIME
AND WE CANNOT WAIT TO GET THIS
THING CRACKING AND TALKING TO
YOU AT PRACTICES AND GAMES.
IT IS TIME TO GET IT BACK GOING.
ANTHONY: THANK YOU GUYS.
CHRIS: THANKS, A.D.
GOTTA LET HIM GO.
ALLIE: I DON'T LIKE WHEN THEY
TELL US THAT.
[LAUGHTER]
CHRIS: IT IS A BIG TOPIC, HIM
PLAYING CENTER.
I'M SURE HE GETS ASKED THAT
QUESTION A LOT.
DID YOU LIKE HIS ANSWER?
I THINK THAT'S WHAT LAKER FANS
WANT TO HEAR JAMES: JAMES:.
-- WHAT LAKER FANS WANT TO HEAR.
JAMES: I LIKE THE ANSWER BASED
ON THE SUCCESS AND HOW HE PLAYS
THE GAME.
THERE IS THE TIME THAT HE SAID
SACRIFICE.
HIM BEING IN THE POST,
ESPECIALLY EARLY IN THE GAME,
DEFENSES ARE GOING TO COLLAPSE.
I PROMISE YOU.
OR ELSE HE WILL HAVE A FIELD
DAY.
I THINK THAT IS THE SACRIFICE HE
HAS TO MAKE IN ORDER FOR THE
PERIMETER SHOOTERS TO GET
COMFORTABLE SHOTS.
MAYBE SOME UNCONTESTED SHOT.
IT IS JUST GOING TO BENEFIT THE
ENTIRE OFTEN.
I LIKE THE FACT THAT HE IS
WILLING TO GO DOWN INTO